it's going to be in your best interest
to go home
Steve my best interest is to help people
that live here in Roy and you're one of
those people an hours-long standoff ends
in a deadly shooting after a Utah man
tells police to quote bring a coroner to
the scene
I'm gonna need a corner
what corner
a coroner I thought you said a corner
no let's Steve I know your dad's talked
about it we can work through anything
man that's I'm going through difficult
times right now you know what I mean
okay don't do anything on July 7th
police in Roy Utah were called to an
apartment complex for reports of a man
with multiple weapons hello
hello this is Weber 911
am I right speaking to you I think we
were disconnected I think we were I need
a hey what's going on at that address I
have the address here
um he is starting to commit suicide he
has guns in the house his mother's in
the house
and has he given you a method as he said
he's going to use the guns or what
exactly did they say
yes
his name is Stephen Kirkman callers told
9-1-1 dispatch the suspect 39-year-old
Stephen Kirkman was making suicidal
statements
I need you guys to get there his mom's
in the house okay we have officers on
the way now okay what exactly did he say
to you
um
take care of it sister
I'm so sorry can you say that again
I can't I can understand you sorry
he said to take care of his sister
because he was killing himself body
camera video shows Roy police officers
approached the front door where
kirkman's mother is standing in the
doorway
on this Landing this door's open
taser
Steve come out here man Steve
let me see your hands
where's the gun
ma'am come out here is it the rifle
hey let me see your hands
come out ma'am no no
back out back out ma'am
come out
ma'am you're making this worse at first
kirkman's mother refuses to leave the
area but officers eventually get her
away from the apartment
you got somebody else he's got in the 88
tournament she's refusing to come out
I know you got her right here
help
yeah ma'am I need you we want to help
him but you got to come out
back down
come on
anyone else okay
what proceeds next is a standoff that
lasts for hours as officers work to calm
Kirkman and bring him help
it looks like it's a it's a rifle
the rifle Put the gun down
it looks like it's a
it looks like it's a shotgun
drop it
listen hey you know me hey we talk all
the time bro no if you put the gun down
Put the gun down I'm not gonna come up
there with the gun in hand a ring
doorbell camera recording shows
kirkman's actions mid standoff as he
comes outside and sets down two weapons
[Music]
nice job
[Applause]
next officers speak to Kirkman over the
phone reassuring him mental health
experts are on the scene you put on
speakerphone for just a second
hey hey Steve I'm officer here I got
your dad here we got some help down here
for you we've got the mobile crisis we
got some therapists out here ready to
talk to
so we got some help down here we're just
waiting on you we got your dad right
here who wants to talk to you as well
you've committed no crimes all right we
you're experiencing uh
uh an outcry for help which we need to
give to you man
okay yep
and what are those things Steve
don't want to harm any of you because I
need like all of you appreciate it Steve
we we like you as well
anyone comes
in this moment
um Steve I understand this we're not
coming to the door
all right
Workman then tells officers it's in
their best interest to leave the area
and threaten shooting through the door
Steve my best interest is to help people
that live here in Roy and you're one of
those people
okay
one of the few things is about to happen
and we're not coming to the door Steve
fire around out that door
where you're gonna leave
as officers work to evacuate the
apartments underneath kirkman's he makes
concerning statements hey Steve so what
we got to do is we just got to get those
people that are right below you out and
we are leaving okay
that's what you want right that's what
we can do
okay we're not coming up to your story
we're not coming up to the third level
we just got to get the people out of the
second levels all
right I am
what's that
bar is on you that's all right it
what do you want to do you want to come
out of the while we go get the second
tiers
you can leave them there they're not
going to be harmed I know Steve but it's
we gotta also look out just to make sure
I I believe that I believe that you that
you would uh won't harm them but they
are also sitting there just really
scared so part of our job is also to
make sure that they're safe so we'll get
them out if that's good and we'll let
you stay here and uh I mean if you if
you don't want to accept the help that
we're trying to give you we will leave
okay
but we got to get those people out of
the second level first
Steve we're not even coming to the third
level
okay we're not coming to the third level
down through the door well we're not
going to do that
that's the bad idea yeah
okay well don't grab the shotgun though
Steve just leave the shotgun there
we're not coming to the third level
and come back inside
well we're not gonna we're not come to
the to your level Steve so I don't know
what what you need the shotgun for
let's bring it back inside in my
position Kirkman then insists he needs
to grab his weapon
he's in there
I'm not gonna harm you I'm not gonna
harm any of you drop
ping my man
I'm not gonna harm any of you
it's then that Kirkman makes the
chilling comment about a coroner and
mentions a body count
I'm gonna need a corner
yep
what corner
a coroner I thought you said a corner
no let's Steve I know your dad's talked
about it we can work through anything
man that's I'm going through difficult
times right now you know what I mean
okay don't do anything
zero that's zero I want zero bodies
tell me tell me uh tell me what
you think
number two
in the end Kirkman comes out of the
apartment armed with a rifle points it
at First Responders and racks the gun
that's when two officers opened fire
he's raising the shotgun
Dave
we need you to put the gun down we need
you to come to the front door with
nothing in your hands please
what's he doing
we need you to come to front
of the front of your hands so he's got
us huh yeah so he's got to still be on
the thing because he's split the Steve
we understand you're believing the
screen the screen door back closed
Dave we need to get you medical help
calm down or come down the stairs of God
he's aiming it he's aiming it over here
he's pointing it like
okay he just racked it
First Responders performed life-saving
measures on Kirkman but he was
pronounced dead at the scene the
shooting is still under investigation
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie